nous leur demandons de continuer à
réduire leurs émissions mais
puisqu'elles sont dans un monde de
concurrence et que nos partenaires
commerciaux
l'ontario laisse les états unis les
certains juridique et au mondial le
terrifie pas le carbone il faut bien je
les ai aidés
normand mousseau dirige l'institut de
l'énergie trottier il a coprésidé la
commission sur les enjeux énergétiques
du québec montfort normand mousseau
enfin il est donc l'objectif du
gouvernement
l'objectif c'est la réduction des
émissions de gaz et vsat dans le secteur
industriel avec un objectif qui est
intéressant parce qu'on s'aligne
maintenant sur une cible de 2050 dont
80% de réduction de gaz à effet de serre
plutôt que de s'arrêter seulement en
pourquoi c'est intéressant d'aller
jusqu'à 2050 on repousse pas 2050 non en
fait on accélère parce que pour être
pour être arrivé à 2050 atteint il faut
réduire plus vite que si on ciblait
seulement 2030 et ça permet aux
industries de se projeter d'aller
chercher leurs investissements sur une
échelle de temps qui est plus grande en
termes de planification
mais aujourd'hui donc de rembourser les
grandes industries en quelque sorte pour
qu'elle investisse ensuite dans des
projets verts est ce que c'est une
approche conciliante est ce que c'est la
bonne approche pour accompagner les
entreprises le fonds vert fut marché du
carbone ne sont pas là pour faire de
larges pour rapporter de l'argent au
gouvernement mais bien pour réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet serre si en
remettant à l'argent aux industries en
leur exigeant de dire vous fait piger
dans votre compte mais vous devez mettre
le même montant de votre argent
directement on arrive à réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet serre plus vite
ou moins respecté nos engagements
ben tout le monde est gagnant l'objectif
c'est vraiment pas de dire il faut faire
payer les industries l'objectif c'est il
faut réduire les émissions de ges et
donc réduire les émissions si ce qui est
exigé
on retourne de l'argent pour investir
dans des projets verts et à terme ont
réussi à émettre moins de gaz à effet de
serre c'est le soir c'est tout le sens
de ce programme
mais vous pensez que c'est le bon
programme je pense à mon programme parce
qu'il permet il donne d'aidé
permet aux inscrits d'investir donc si
elles avancent dans leur transformation
mais sont moins pénalisées ces avances
pas mais l'argent qu'elles ont payé ayez
perdu après quelques années
c'est important de comprendre qu'en ce
moment on donne des permis de pollution
ou en tout cas des allocations aux
entreprises
on leur donne gratuitement actuelle
c'est ça avec un plafond qui diminue
année après année fait son chemin mais
là il va descendre plus rapidement ce
plafond la et mais une partie du de
cette descente là pour être remboursé si
l'industrie fait ces efforts ok alors on
appris on a préparé deux graphiques qui
sont tirées des documents du
gouvernement du québec pour bien voir ce
que ça veut dire exactement ce qu'on
appelle l'allocation totale aux
entreprises allocations gratuites
presque 100% avec une petite partie sur
les droits mis en consigne c'est à dire
c'est de l'argent remboursé pour
résister un peu recevoir si on investit
si on investit et l'effort minimal
attendu et on voit de plus en plus d'ici
2030 que les locations gratuites va
baisser et que de plus en plus il y aura
des exigences aux entreprises voilà et
cette allocation gratuite là est basé
sur le prix mondial du carbone donc si
le restant de la planète mais tu es un
prix sur le carbone plus agressif mais
le québec s'ajusterait et diminuerait la
location gratuite parce que cette
allocation là est vraiment destiné à
garder l'industrie concurrentiel si le
reste du monde augmente les coûts mais
pour maintenir la concurrence on n'a pas
besoin de donner autant de crédit et
donc on imagine le cerveau jusqu'à 2030
mais on imagine d'antan que la location
gratuite va baisser baisser baisser et
donc qu'il y aura un engagement de la
part des entreprises à réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre c'est
ça voilà j'ai compris parfait deuxième
tableau c'est les plafonds d'émissions
donc pour voir le 2ème graphique qui ont
qu'on va voir apparaître ce sont les
plafonds d'émissions
d'une année à l'autre donc de 2013 à
on va devoir le voici donc en tonnes
métriques presse a décrit tonnes de co2
donc les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre qui sont appelés à décroître ça
c'est le secteur énergétique ici c'est
pas le lançant c'est le secteur qui est
couvert par le marché du carbone pour
l'ensemble des émissions du québec qui
sont un peu plus élevés et ce qu'on voit
ici c'est qu'on se projette avec une
réduction de 37 et demi pour cent par
rapport à 90 et c'est cette courbe là
qu'on voit pourquoi il ya une ligne
rouge qui est plus basse au début ce
parce que en 2013 2015 le sec toute
l'économie était pas soumise aux aspects
du marché du carbone et à partir de 2015
mais il ya tout un secteur qui arrive le
secteur des carburants qui rentrait dans
le marché c'est le seul sou convoi est
donc ce sont les émissions qui devront
baisser d'année en année au delà des
émissions faut payer ça c'est oui voila
voila mais en fait une partie de ça
parce que tout ce qui est combustibles
fossiles carburants et tout on paye 100
% des émissions ont fait là le ski
mentionné aujourd'hui ton passé
seulement les émissions liées aux grands
émetteurs ce qui met plus que 25 mille
tonnes par année qui sont quelques
dizaines et donc ses grands émetteurs
devront réduire mais certains grands
émetteurs devront réduire moins que
d'autres pensent aux cimenteries
pourquoi parce que ce qu'on dit c'est
d'abord le ciment beaucoup d'émissions
de gaz à bâtir par tonne de produit par
valeur ajoutée en termes de
transformation du ciment et que c'est un
marché qui plus compétitif que d'autres
marchés encore une fois on peut
argumenter de est ce que c'est ça prête
un peu plus sévère ou moins sévères mais
la pente au moins bonne oui la pente est
bonne donc vous pensez que c'est une
bonne affaire l'objectif d'aujourd'hui
que c'est un boucle
oui je pense est un programme
intelligent après il faudra voir à la
marge mais en gros c'est quelque chose
qui va qui ne pénalisera pas les
industries mais qu'ils engagent as à
faire des transforme ce que nous
n'avions pas jusqu'à maintenant on ne
pourrait pas nécessairement c'est sur
les industries pour faire la
transformation bien merci beaucoup c'est
moi qui va venir si bien